optimizing gk clusters for cost is not a
one-time exercise
it's a longer journey to shift team and
organizational culture
while incrementally implementing best
practices
one of these best practices is to use
monitoring systems specific to gke
to help establish cost optimization as a
discipline
let's take a look at why we should do
this and how it can be done
as you may have seen in previous videos
from this series there are a handful of
critical areas
to practice cost optimization in a gke
environment
we'll focus on three of these areas and
how they fit into a monitoring system
for cost optimization specifically
culture
bin packing and app right sizing let's
start by discussing culture
teams who own gke environments are not
simply trying to drive down costs
while ignoring everything else they
instead must balance cost saving
techniques
while ensuring the applications running
on gke are still performant
stable and continue to deliver value to
their users
to effectively balance all of this teams
have begun incorporating cloud financial
management
or fin-ops into their culture this is
the practice of building systems for
financial accountability in the
pay-as-you-go cloud world
now put this into the context of
kubernetes rapid adoption of kubernetes
in particular
means that many teams are still learning
and establishing their own best
practices
this is true when it comes to managing
the cost of running their clusters
especially as they grow
continuous monitoring of these
environments enables the necessary
cultural shift
when teams have proper tooling and data
at their disposal to practice cost
optimization
the awareness shifts the discipline
earlier in the software development
lifecycle so what specifically should we
aim to accomplish with monitoring here
first we'll want to focus on a cluster
administrator centric monitoring system
we can do so with a focus on cluster bin
packing
bin packing is the ability to
effectively schedule workloads
across nodes in a cluster in such a way
that ensures there are little wasted
resources
cpu and memory for example efficient bin
packing is achieved with a real-time
understanding
of how much resources workloads request
and how those workloads
fit into the various amounts of
allocatable resources
that the vms in the cluster have
available
cluster administrators when empowered
with the right monitoring data
can improve how they support cluster
tenants while also ensuring that
provision infrastructure is not wasted
we can even set up alerting policies on
the data collected for the most
egregious cases of over provisioning
to proactively kick off the process of
cost optimization
developers can also benefit from a
different perspective
a monitoring system that captures
recommendations for app right sizing
this enables developers to better
understand how much of their requested
resources
are actually being utilized by their
applications
with a deep understanding of scenarios
where they may be over provisioned in
their workload requests
developers can make informed decisions
on how they can easily reduce cost
now that we've looked at the importance
of culture bin packing
and app right sizing for gk cost
optimization the next step
is setting up the monitoring system be
sure to check out the paper linked in
the description
we publish an end-to-end guide on how
you can set up such a monitoring system
with google cloud monitoring in the next
video
we'll cover how cluster administrators
can set up monitoring for cluster bin
packing
to optimize costs on gke stay tuned
you